begin here with russia increasing its
attacks on ukraine including on kiev the
capital what had recently threatened to
invade before retreating explosions were
reported there this morning and in the
western city of levive
the bodies of more than 900 civilians
have been found near keeve police said
most had been shot dead and likely
executed
in the south ukrainian forces are trying
to hold on to the besieged port city of
mariopol ukrainian president vlodimir
zelinski is again urging the west to do
more he said in his friday address the
economic sanctions on russia are painful
but not severe enough to stop russia's
offensive
holly williams is south of kiev with the
latest holly good morning
good morning president zielinski claimed
in a video message last night that the
length of this war and how many
ukrainians are killed will be decided by
how quickly ukraine's friends supply it
with weapons and enforce an oil embargo
against russia
nadezhda alexandrova says she wanted to
flee her home in eastern ukraine but
left it too late her son sergey was
killed by russian shelling in their
apartment
the glass from the window fell down she
says and i saw him lying in a pool of
blood
russian forces failed to capture
ukraine's capital kiev plagued by
military failures and a ukrainian
resistance much tougher than many
expected but in eastern ukraine they're
still being pummeled from the air and
bracing for a fresh assault as russian
forces regrouped civilians are in the
firing line and russia stands accused of
war crimes
in the southern city of kriviri
officials say they managed to stop
russian forces seizing control of this
strategically important airport at the
start of the war
their plan was low tech but ingenious
parking trucks and construction vehicles
on the runway
and this one looks like a mining truck
down here is this mine truck mining from
the from one of the local mines
alexander vilcool is the head of the
military administration and told us it
was his idea
did the russians actually try to land
here
on the second day of the war a cargo
plane normally used by airborne troops
and three fighter jets tried to land he
told us they descended to about 200
meters made a few circles and once they
realized they couldn't land they left
with ukrainian forces massively
outgunned by russia they've made up for
it with smarts and creativity but vilcal
told us they can't win the war without
more weapons from the west
what do you need
we need fighter jets tanks missiles the
whole spectrum of weapons he told us
this special forces officer showed us
the wreckage of a russian missile that
she says they shot down and presented us
with some fragments as a gift
but other russian missiles are hitting
their targets and leaving carnage
president zielenski wants europe to end
its energy dependence on russia and stop
the flow of cash that it funnels to
moscow he's even accused some european
countries of quote earning their money
from other people's blood
michelle
holly thank you well